was on Bumble and I swiped I'm at this
guy named Alex he asked me out on a date
like Froyo Cuts guys on so we went we
met for Froyo on the first date he's
like I'm in Fitness you're in Fitness
you're super ambitious I'm super
ambitious like let's just do something
together what people don't know is that
Layla already had a really profitable
business at that time and so for her to
quit doing her thing I had to show that
this was a superior opportunity vehicle
so some people were like oh she's only
in it for the money as she should be if
you're making a business decision I
think that if you're going to quit what
you're doing to start with a partner
make sure it makes sense for you
individually and one of the things we
did early on was I said hey if this
relationship doesn't come with it this
still has to make sense for you
financially